bien mesdames messieurs bonjour merci
d'être là même si je sais que vous ne
venez pas uniquement pour le point de la
haute autorité ont souhaité vous donner
quelques informations puisque maintenant
nous sommes dans la dernière semaine de
campagne avant le scrutin
et puis surtout si vous en avez bien sûr
pouvoir répondre à vos questions alors
quelques éléments chiffre est tout
d'abord vous souvenez que lorsque l'on a
arrêté la liste électorale au mois de
septembre nous étions à 234 1908
électeurs potentiels ce chiffre a
légèrement baissé pour une raison simple
c'est qu'au fur et à mesure que nous
communiquons avec les adhérents nous
sommes informés de certains décès donc
ne soyez pas surpris
le nombre définitif des lecteurs qui
sera affichée sur la base duquel nous
des comptes ronds les résultats et de
deux cent trente quatre mille cinq cent
cinquante six adhérents à jour de
cotisation deuxième élément je vous
rappelle que le scrutin était
électronique qui sera donc ouvert samedi
à partir de 20h heure de paris et qu'il
sera clos à 20h dimanche heure de paris
ça permet donc à tout adhérent qu'ils
souhaitent de voter
d'où qu'ils soient dans cette séquence
de 24 heures et ensuite à des horaires
qu'ils nous ont proposé un certain
nombre de lieux de vote ont été ouverts
c'est à dire des lieux dans lesquels les
adhérents pourront se déplacer pour en
réalité voté comme ils le feraient de
chez eux c'est à dire sur la base d'un
ordinateur ou d'une tablette
ces lieux de vote sont au nombre de 250
et 1
principalement métropole quelques uns en
outre mer
le choix a été librement proposé
d'ouvrir ou non des lieux de vote par
les fédérations du parti et nous avons
en revanche validé individuellement
chacun de ces lieux
je précise aussi que la haute autorité a
eu une attention particulière sur les
éventuelles questions de sécurité raison
pour laquelle nous sommes entrés en
contact avec le ministère de l'intérieur
sur ces questions là qui donc est
informé de l'implantation de chacun des
lieux de vote et qui veillera à ce que
des rondes supplémentaires soient
organisées et bien sûr est en contact
avec nous et avec les présidents de
lieux de vote
s'il ya lieu 3e série d'éléments la
question qui naturellement vous
intéresse du dépouillement et de l'heure
de la non ce des résultats le scrutin
étant clos à 20 heures comme d'habitude
pour un vote électronique comme pour un
vote physique si quelqu'un accède au
site à 19h59 nous laissons évidemment
achevé son vote donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya quelques minutes possibles
supplémentaires de fermeture définitive
du dispositif
on peut imaginer une fois que tous les
contrôles informatiques sont faits avant
lancement du dépouillement
quoi qu'il arrive que nous ayons des
résultats avant 21h je peux pas vous
donner d'heure précise
vous avez peut-être le souvenir que en
2014 nous avions fait une annonce des
résultats un peu avant 20h30 de mémoire
donc il n'ya pas de raison que les
choses se passent différemment
et puis enfin sur les 24 heures du
scrutin comme en 2014
les membres de la haute autorité seront
ici dans un une salle qui nous est
dédiée dont le bâtiment du parti les
représentants des candidats seront
également physiquement présentes pendant
la totalité des 24 heures du scrutin
cette présence elle se justifie
évidemment par la surveillance du bon
déroulement
du dispositif et la possibilité de
réagir s'il y avait la moindre
difficulté
elle se justifie aussi par le fait que
nous aurons pendant ces 24 heures des
lignes téléphoniques qui seront ouvertes
alors bien sûr il s'agit pas de régler
le contentieux électoral éventuelles sur
le siège et en temps réel mais en
revanche de pouvoir prendre toutes les
décisions qui seraient nécessaires
peut-être n'y at-il aucune à prendre
mais toutes les décisions qui seraient
nécessaires pour garantir que les
électeurs puissent bien voter pendant
les 24 heures donc ça ne préjuge
évidemment pas de l'éventualité ensuite
après l'annoncé des résultats
d'éventuels recours qui serait formée
devant nous et qui nous amènerait à
faire une proclamation des résultats
après examen de ces recours ont comme
d'habitude on a trois temps le temps du
scrutin proprement dit le temps de la
non ce qui est provisoire et puis enfin
le temps de la proclamation
après vérification le cas échéant des
contentieux enfin toute dernière chose
le parti a mis en place et elle
fonctionne donc d'ores et déjà depuis
maintenant
quinze jours une cellule téléphonique
donc un centrale d'appels téléphoniques
qui permet d'accompagner les adhérents
soit dans des interrogations qu'ils ont
sur le déroulement du scrutin
même si par ailleurs ils ont été je
pense assez largement informés par
l'envoi du magazine de l'union et puis
2e série d'éléments aussi puisque les
adhérents doivent s'identifier avec
d'une part des codes et mot de passe qui
l'ont reçu par courrier à leur domicile
et d'autre part par leur numéro
d'adhérent et bien il peut arriver que
certains adhérents
pris de panique à l'idée de ne pas
retrouver leur carte d'adhérent passe un
coup de fil pour récupérer ce sésame qui
leur permettra de participer au scrutin
voilà en quelques mots vous le voyez ce
que je souhaitais vous dire sur le
déroulement du scrutin
si vous avez des questions naturellement
bonjour bonjour bureaux qui seront
ouverts ce sera pour des votes manuelle
ou non non alors on est sur un scrutin
totalement et 100% électronique
simplement là encore comme en 2014
l'idée est que ça reste un moment
évidemment important de la vie du parti
tout ça est quand même assez conditionné
aussi par des contraintes
météorologiques nous sommes au mois de
décembre on a déjà vu le week-end
dernier qui pouvait y avoir des éléments
pas complètement déchaînés mais qui
incite plutôt à rester chez soi toujours
est il que ce sont donc des lieux ou des
ordinateur ou tablette sont mis à
disposition des adhérents néanmoins et
là encore comme en 2014 le choix qui a
été fait c'est d'avoir une tenue de ce
lieu de vote c'est pour ça que je parle
de lieux et pas de bureau un une tenue
de ce lieu de vote qui soient conformes
à ce qu'on rencontre habituellement dans
les élections donc un président des
assesseurs
tous ces gens là ont été validés il ya
maintenant plusieurs semaines on a même
prévu au cas où un suppléant pour chacun
des lieux de vote
et puis on leur a demandé de tenir un
procès verbal dont tout simplement
d'enregistrer la liste des électeurs qui
viendront voter dans ce lieu mais ça
reste un scrutin électronique dans des
conditions rigoureusement identique à
quelqu'un qui voteraient depuis chez lui
ou où qu'ils soient dans le monde alors
les délais de recours sont fixées par
les statuts on est sur un délai de 24
heures après clôture et annonce des
résultats
c'est un délégué cours mais c'est un
délai qui est nécessairement court
puisque je vous rappelle qu'on est sur
une élection qui est programmé sur deux
tours et que par définition il n'y a
qu'une semaine entre les deux tours que
donc six recours il ya il est évidemment
important de pouvoir les examiner
rapidement parce que vous donnerez le
nombre de participants au scrutin
vous aurez alors vous aurez tout puisque
en scrutin électronique vous aurez tous
j'allais dire à quelques secondes près
en même temps que nous l'aurons
puisqu'en scrutin électronique
par définition le dépouillement est
centralisé est unique puisque c'est une
seule urne électronique virtuelle et
donc vous aurez le détail du nombre de
votants est de la répartition numérique
d'ailleurs nous donnerons c'est vous
plutôt qu'ils feraient les pourcentages
plutôt que nous mais la répartition
numérique par candidat alors les
résultats seront aussi communiquer par
département notre priorité c'est d'avoir
les résultats globaux et par département
nous aurons les éléments
vraisemblablement le lendemain tout cas
c'est la date limite à laquelle s'est
engagée notre prestataire
je précise aussi bien sûr que comme nous
ne saurons pas d'où physiquement les
adhérents ont voté qu'il s'agira d'une
répartition par département sur la base
de leur département d'inscription en
tant qu'adhérent c'est à dire que
lorsque les codes de vote ont été
générés par le prestataire
on a intégré dans cette génération des
codes dont dans la production des codes
un élément de localisation
départementale qui leur département
d'inscription alors ça va un parti c'est
une association dont il ya un système
d'adhésion et l'adhésion elle se
manifeste par le paiement d'une
cotisation alors les choses sont
juridiquement assez simple c'est que il
ya en fait trois cas de figure il ya
l'adhérent qui a bien cotisé qui pour
nous est à jour de cotisation et qu'il
soit ou non à un moment donné de sa vie
d'adhérents tenté d'abandonner nous ne
pouvons rien y faire puisque
juridiquement il est toujours adhérent
c'est la non reprise à sion l'année
suivante qui le fera disparaître des
fichiers après on a le deuxième cas de
figure est là aussi par anticipation je
réponds à la question peut-être
c'est le cas de figure d'un adhérent qui
a fait l'objet d'une procédure
d'exclusion et dans ce cas là qu'on en a
été tenue et le troisième cas de figure
c'est
lui des éventuelles suspensions c'est un
cas qu'on rencontre là encore dans tous
les partis est classiquement et donc
même système quand on est suspendu on
est suspendu de ses droits et donc en
particulier du droit de vote mais donc
ce qu'ils soient dans un mouvement
d'humeur momentanée soit de manière plus
sérieuse et à long terme ont indiqué
qu'ils ne n'était plus membre du parti
ont néanmoins reçu leurs codes puisque
pour nous juridiquement et
administrativement ils sont à jour de
cotisation
oui des précautions ont elles été prises
pour assurer la sécurité informatique de
ce scrutin qui est 100% électronique
quelques-unes wind quand même je vous
rassure
alors oui les sécurités bon d'abord on
avait établi un cahier des charges très
précis vis-à-vis de notre prestataire en
termes de contrôle je rajoute qu'il ya
un certain nombre de prescriptions qui
ont été établies par la cnil depuis
longtemps maintenant sur les votes
électroniques et en particulier les
votes dans le cadre d'organismes
politique
donc elles sont toutes respectées en
atteste un rapport établi par un expert
informatique que nous avons diligenté et
puis nous avons également demandé à cet
expert informatique de procéder à un
certain nombre de contrôles qui ne sont
pas exigées par la cnil mais qui sont
notamment tous les contrôles en termes
de résistance du site du vote résistance
en particulier ou éventuelle tentative
d'intrusion ou autres donc en l'état
en plus d'un certain nombre de
mécanismes de contrôle en temps réel que
nous avons mis en place et dans le
détail desquels je n'entre pas parce que
si je voulais le dévoile vous saurez
quels sont nos mécanismes de contrôle et
il pourrait être moins efficace je pense
que l'on peut considérer en tout cas que
le maximum a été fait est-ce que vous
avez un site de repli
au delà du président républicain point
fr alors ainsi 2 qu'est ce que vous
appelez un site de repli qui permettra
aux adhérents de voter si celui ci est
attaquée ou oui alors il ya un système
de double là encore on est dans les
exigences j'allais dire classique
minimes allons il ya des systèmes de
double site des systèmes de back up
comme dit les informaticiens
tout a été aussi mis en place pour parer
le cas échéant un dysfonctionnement de
l'hébergeur en tout cas un
dysfonctionnement sur un des serveurs de
l'hébergeur
après voilà la suite des opérations nous
dira ce qu'il en est mais normalement
toutes les précautions a été prise au vu
de ce qui est raisonnablement
imaginables en revanche si nous avons
une coupure générale et mondial
d'électricité
je vous confirme que là nous ne pouvons
pas faire grand chose est ce que les
résultats seront d'abord publié sur
internet où ce sera d'abord temps votre
voix qu'on apprendra les résultats
vraisemblablement ce sera d'abord dans
ma voix comme vous dites et on les
mettra on l'est on lui rend la vie dure
à dans le cas d'un communiqué en temps
réel absolument
une question pratique juste je suis
adhérente j'ai mon code qui ait dégénéré
je peux voter depuis un café
vous pouvez voter depuis un café si vous
avez tous les éléments dès lors que vous
avez soit téléphone ou une tablette en
connexion 3g minimum évidemment soin
ensuite de chez vous 2 chez des amis de
votre lieu de vacances absolument de
vous le souhaitez plus d'autres
questions à écouter je vous remercie et
je laisse donc la place au point presse
hebdomadaire du parti
merci beaucoup
je